bonjour claude lise bonjour président de
l'assemblée de martinique la martinique
claude lise qui rentre dans une année
électorale chargée présidentielles au
mois de mai législatives en juin si la
taurian septembre les candidats iront au
devant d'une population lassée par un
porte-monnaie crever que devise hausse
des impôts locaux les tacles 19 centimes
sur le gazole 11 centimes sur le sans
plomb ce sont des taxes qui ne passe pas
comment vous l'expliquez vous entends
qui lui aurait coûté je crois qu'il faut
bien se rendre compte que cela témoigne
d'une situation qui est qui est grave la
situation d'abreu donne à notre économie
donc il y à ddo recettes ils viennent de
l'économie d'un marche de l'économie
dans les collectivités sont privés
puissent il ya surtout un désengagement
de l'état qui est important alors c'est
vrai qu'on n'entend que c'est une
ancienne que nous répétons ça tout le
temps mais c'est un geste
c'est un fait ça veut dire que les
jeunes aujourd'hui en place mme ne sont
ne font pas preuve d'ingénierie pour
pouvoir à nouveau concept s'inspire bien
sûr les élus essaient de faire le
maximum alors je veux quand même dire
qu'il faut faire le départ entre les
mauvais gestionnaires parce qu'il y en a
il ya des gens on va pas refaire le
match no no no no mais il ya des gens
qui gèrent mal bon et puis y en a même
qui laissent leur mauvaise gestion a
d'autres qui en hérite
bon et puis il y a ce qui vient de la
situation économique sur les dix longues
et des situations sur lesquelles n'avons
pas une prise immédiate
bien entendu ceux qui y relève du
désengagement de l'état je vous donne un
seul exemple l'une des des principales
dotations de l'état pour une
collectivité comme la nôtre c'est ce
qu'on appelle la dotation globale de
fonctionnement
et bien cette année nous aurons 10
millions de moins l'année dernière il
avait déjà 10 millions de moins depuis
ça a baissé on a parlé des problèmes de
l'espace sud
ben là aussi c'est la dgf cette même
dotation pour pour l'espace autre baisse
depuis trois quatre ans
plus de 1 million 3 donc si vous voulez
ça ce sont des éléments des éléments qui
montrent que nous nous sommes dans une
période extrêmement difficile et il faut
que les élus bien entendu cherche le
moyen de compenser avoriaz il ya 2 il ya
deux moyens
bon comme ça s'agissait pas quand il
s'agit d'un investissement
et bien c'est le recours à l'emprunt et
quand on quand on peut dans la mesure où
c'est possible
et puis pour ce qui est du
fonctionnement bien mais c'est le seul
moyen est sinon soyons heureux les et
pauvres entre les nobles et sinon vous
avez des besoins
vous avez des besoins que vous ne pouvez
que vous ne pourrez pas satisfaire est
ce qu'il faut c'est bien entendu être
extrêmement modéré on ne peut pas
systématiquement refusé toute
augmentation mais je veux signaler que
par exemple vous avez fait allusion à
des taxes comme par exemple la taxe co2
sur les carburants
on savait zim deux coups le 1er janvier
non il faut quand même dire que depuis
1998 en 2016 depuis 1998 il n'y a pas eu
la moindre augmentation et c'est une
légère augmentation alors bien entendu
elle et elle est forcément douloureuses
mais si la collectivité ne fait pas ce
petit effort que quelques millions de
remise dans un pays aux relations il y
aura des difficultés à la population
suisse a bien besoin d'enlever à la
compilation d'articles vous dites qu'il
faut aborder les élections qui viennent
là en citoyen responsable
alors question club d'ici croient être
citoyen responsable quand on sait
soulever contre la vie chère à 1 - 2 et
- de 10 ans après est belle les prix
continuent d'exploser c'est quoi être
responsable lorsqu'on augmente les
impôts et que les ordures sont toujours
pas ramassés en temps et en heure c'est
quoi être responsable quand on augmente
les taxes sur l'essence et qu'on a
éjecté déjà des millions sur un tcsp qui
n'est pas pour le fil alternatif pour
les usagers martiniquais vous énuméré
toute une série de
deux constats du réveillon mais qui ne
relèvent pas des mêmes responsabilités
bon évidemment chacun sait ce qu'on dit
c'est la même bête chacun doit faire
face à ses propres responsabilités
quand je dis que les citoyens doivent
prennent leurs responsabilités il suffit
pas de dire oui c'est lui le tout paris
et ces derniers n'ont tous les éléments
pêcher tout le monde de la population
nos dix églises mais je comprends parce
que moi-même moi même aussi je je je me
plais la situation mais franchement je
suis un citoyen comme les autres et puis
je je je suis bi m suivi comme toujours
sonné oui comme les ordures ne sont pas
ramassées comme il faut et c'est bien on
s'est bien entendu je proteste je dis
qu'on ne peut pas simplement protester
puis mettre tout le monde dans le même
sac
bon dans une période de difficultés il
faut voir ce qu'ils font des efforts de
gestion sérieuse ce qui évite
l'aventurisme financiers et budgétaires
comme on en a vu
et puis ceux qui essaient de tout en
répondant aux besoins de la population
qui essaie ce soit le gérer avec rigueur
sérieux et ce sera le shérif du groupe
apg ans alors des élections vers je
crois que nous démontrons en ce moment
nous avons hérité d'un passif mais
épouvantable je n'ai jamais vu ça entre
déficit multiples entre engagement
aventuriste des 4 milliards 4,2
d'engagement a lancé par fernando plus
de bâche deschamps semblait pas d être
responsable pour les citoyens c'est
écouter ça c'est pas juger les gens
simplement à l'organisateur que d
écouter l'ordre leur baratin élections
c'est voir ce qu'ils ont à l'est moi je
vois des gens qui aujourd'hui se
présente aux élections avec une
désinvolture lorsqu'ils ont laissé des
carcasses thouars les deux kivus qu'ils
ont laissé des catastrophes dans une
collectivité co2 ou parlez de qui les
les citoyens sauront le moment venu
appréciez les bilans des jeux et alors
vous voulez parler certainement des
élections initiative et dans le centre
dans le centre atlantique hier nous
avons reçu josette manin candidate de
pmm ensemble une martinique nouvelle
dans cette circonscription
une candidature unique de l'actuelle
opposition en face d'elle
il devrait y avoir on va faire la liste
car ils nous sont de bas payant chance
fabrice doute d'une ont soutenu par
alfred marie-jeanne est quelqu'un de
votre camp politique
christian verneuil du rdr votre alliance
politique est entré de désapprendre les
recettes de la victoire de décembre 2006
ligne est mort à du tout dès le départ
nous avions dit qu'il y avait une
alliance de gestion nous nous étions
engagés sur cinq ans puisque cette
mandature 1,9 à durée de cinq ans nous
nous étions engagés sur un projet pour
la martinique
ils ont mis d'accord nous avons
travaillé ensemble à ce projet et nous
avions dit dès le départ que il n'y
avait pas fusion dilution des
différentes composantes de de cette
majorité grand ensemble et chacun garde
son identité sauf qu'il est maintenant
candidat unique dans son premier duel
face à eux trois quatre cinq six profite
d'un passage lorsque moi je réfléchis
avec mes amis la situation lorsque nous
discutons de ce qu'il faut faire nous ne
le faisons pas en fonction de madame x
ou de monsieur y
bon nous nous essayons de faire entendre
notre voix
alors là où il est possible ou bien où
il est indispensable de se réunir dès le
premier tour si les conditions se
trouvent réunies et bien nous sommes
d'accord c'est ce qui va se passer
je prends un exemple le sens de la
fusion pensait que le bon sens je pense
que dans le sud
il lui a probablement dès le premier
tour tout le grand semblaient réunies
bon probablement à fort de france
et puis dans les deux autres
circonscriptions manifestement aussi
bien dans le nom que donne au centre
atlantique
il y aura l'expression de plusieurs
composants du grand ensemble et mais
rassurez vous les savez on vous dit que
réside le lit de votre défaite à venir
mais non mais attendez nous ne pouvons
pas demander aux parties de ce musée est
de n'avoir plus d'expressions excellent
mon parti sur les problèmes de
démocratie a des choses à dire
vous savez que pour nous c'est un
élément extrêmement important également
sur la question de lui de 2,2 du
socialisme
bon nous avons des choses à dire notre
conception de socialisme démocratique
dont il faut qu'on fasse entendre au
moins dans une ou deux circonscriptions
le point de vue du parti et tout ça
enrichit la réflexion des citoyens
s'agit pas simplement de faire comme
d'autres de la cuisine électoraliste et
puis d'être uniquement des des
pourvoyeurs de candidats les autres en
face j'ai l'impression que c'est
uniquement de la cuisine électoraliste
mois ils ont réussi à s'entendre c'est
dur pour lui mais c'est en apparaissant
comme yannick mans dans la répartition
de postes c'est c'est pas forcément
profitable à l'avenir de la martinique
plutôt parler de dynamique positive au
sein du corps semble à la veille de ce
scrutin de juin pour la population la
dynamique est laid et les dans la
gestion des affaires vous avez de la
9ème c'est à dire que nous ne confondons
pas à le fait que nous irons dans
certaines circonscriptions nous exprimer
fait à faire savoir ce que nous pensons
chacun sur un certain nombre de plans
montrer tous les éléments de notre
idéologie propre et puis de notre côté
la gestion des affaires dans la gestion
des affaires
je peux vous dire en prison de
l'assemblée j'entends beaucoup de
critiques
j'ai écouté j'ai rarement vu une
majorité travaillaient dans d'aussi
bonnes conditions
si vous voulez les gens des gens qui se
sont combattus quelquefois des chantiers
qui ne se connaissaient pas je peux
témoigner du fait qu'on travaille cela
me donne en ce moment là vous nous
faites la méthode coué sodano pas du
tout pas du tout
non non vous savez il ya des difficultés
de fonctionnement on n'a pas le temps
d'en parler mais j'en parle suffisamment
yeux il n'y a pas d'opposition jean
claude lise y en a pas on tire tous plus
président que l'autre non non non
alors ça
n'avons probablement pas le temps à
parler mais il y a des difficultés c'est
vrai dans le fonctionnement de l'outil
qu'on nous a donné quelques outils qui a
été mal conçue il faudra revoir il
faudra tout entendu qu'il faut le revoir
parce que nous sommes nous sommes une
collectivité de gestion et on nous a
donné une gouvernance de deux
collectivités qui est dans l'autonomie
c'est à dire qu'on nous a donné un
système qui s'apparente à celui de la
polynésie par exemple ou là une
séparation des pouvoirs mais mais
l'assemblée vote des lois de pays est
alors à ce moment-là le président a à
ses propres services à son propre budget
et c'est donc ce sera la prochaine chute
et donc ce soir le député ceux qui
sortiront des urnes leçon de coaching le
green qui devons retravailler bien
attentivement les succès sur mais là
aujourd'hui je sais que les gens
certains voudraient que je sois en train
de poser des problèmes institutionnels
juridiques et moi je suis pas venu pour
ça
là je suis dans l'action j'essaie de
faire le maximum et j'estime que
précisément dans vu les difficultés que
vous même vous avez soulevé
aujourd'hui ce ne serait pas bien de ma
part de soulever un problème juridique
institutionnel pour dire oui comme il ya
séparation des pouvoirs il faut que j'ai
davantage de moyens externes en jeu
j'agis avec ce que j'ai nous sommes
obligés de bricoler un fonctionnement
avec un système qui a été mal conçu et
qui a été mal conçue volontairement je
le dis et j'avais critiqué cela lors des
débats parlementaires et j'étais
parlementaire
donc je l'avais raison quand je disais
que la loi qui a institué la ctm a été
mal faite
elle a été bâclée et elle a été vicié au
départ pour un certain nombre de raisons
que je n'ai pas le temps d'évoquer la
maintenant et aujourd'hui il faut
qu'avec un instrument qui est imparfait
qui est mal conçu il faut quand même que
nous arrivions à agir c'est ce que nous
faisons que dix présidents d'assemblée
de martinique vous êtes également
secrétaire général du rdr vous rappeler
claude 10 heures lorsque vous avez lancé
ce mouvement nous avions des congrès ou
fallait vraiment cherché un endroit où
s'asseoir au carbet à sainte-marie
aujourd'hui le rdmc quoi ça pèse 3 races
écoutez là on verra comment vous vous
réunissez annonce en tout temps adobuzz
mais comment sort on n'entend pas parler
de nous écouter nous avons certain
nombre d'élus
qui ont des responsabilités à la ctm et
qui travaille souvent à des loyers tenez
pour décider de notre parti est
peut-être celui qui réunit le plus
souvent ces instances je vous signale
qu'à l'époque vous savez faire du bruit
autour de courants on peut même y
affluer des attardés mais non mais non
mais non non non nous ne sommes pas dans
le m'as-tu-vu
nous ne faisons pas semblant et nous
n'essayons pas de données dans le décor
et les apparences je peux vous dire
qu'il ya une vie du parti et que chez
nous tout se passe de manière
extrêmement démocratique au bord des
pots pour la lévée situe depuis ses
ennuis
non seulement on a interrogé les
sections concernées
non seulement le bureau politique le
conseil politique se sont réunies nous
avons organisé une convention du parti
pente irin les décisions de la direction
on a un fonctionnement très démocratique
c'est vrai que nous avons moins de monde
qu'au départ il ya eu beaucoup de
trahison mais nous avons la qualité
nous avons de vrais militants et de
vrais responsables merci d'avoir été ce
matin avec nos clubs visent en appel que
vous êtes président de l'assemblée de
matic et demain nous recevrons thierry
renard qui parlera au nom du candidat
mélenchon que la présidentielle merci
bonne journée mais assez